what the [__] it's cold what hey um
what's this white stuff falling from the
Scott first of all why he's screaming
because I can't hear anything cuz I have
four hoods on right
now they can barely turn this way are
you kidding me y people live
yo it's so cold in
Indianapolis what is this a choice to
live in this like what's the deal cuz my
choice would be
no like what it seems
excessive good luck everybody out there
my nuts have retreated
deep into my body I think they're
hibernating like Bears see in the
spring I really wish your voice would
have gotten high when you did that that
would have been super fun see you in the
spring